housing confidence is the highest it's
been in many years just came out
manufacturing the highest level of
confidence they've had since they
started doing it many years ago and
business it has the highest level of
confidence I was president Trump in the
Cabinet Room earlier today he also
pointed out which he likes to do but
it's a fact look at the chart Dow's up
more than 5,000 points in one years
never done that before
70 new highs for the Dow Jones
Industrials remember when everyone said
the market was just gonna tank the day
after the election and fall through the
floor didn't happen historic tax reform
on top of that 3% GDP growth and a
forecast to potentially do four percent
in the third quarter we'll see if that
happens so what is next
earlier I spoke with White House
economic adviser Gary Cohen and asked
him first of all does he know exactly
when the president is going to actually
put his Donald Trump signature on this
newly passed bill so Martha look the the
House and Senate still have to come back
and fund the government and they're
gonna do that probably over the next day
to two days that will have an impact on
when we sign the tax legislation if they
get the continuing resolution done in
the next two days and they take care of
some of the loose ends will hopefully
try and sign the tax legislation on
Friday if not most likely will sign at
the first week of the new year I I mean
there's the question of the pay-go it's
signed in this year it could mean a
twenty five billion dollar cut to to
Medicaid so you know is that why you
might want to push it into the next
calendar year exactly Martha we're not
gonna do that we would wait till the new
legislative year and sign it next year
we would never put a cut into Medicaid
so does that mean the presence gonna
sign it at mar-a-lago and there any
concerns about the optics of that at all
no no if we sign it next year we're
gonna sign it probably after January 1st
when the president's back and we'll
probably sign it somewhere in the
beginning of next year so you know why
do you think that the bill gets such a
bad rap I guess you know we've seen in
the past that this kind of legislation
has been supported by Democrats
in the past this time around they're
railing against it as Chuck Schumer is
why don't you do Americans have a
negative attitude about corporations in
general do you think you don't want I
think people are gonna change their mind
very quickly on this bill as chairman
Brady said today there's three important
dates I'm going to touch on one of the
important dates the important date is
February 1st by February 1st the IRS
will have the new tax withholding tables
out people will see a difference in
their paycheck they will see more
take-home pay on February 1st
right now for some reason people don't
think they're getting a tax cut they
don't understand that they are actually
getting a tax cut when people actually
see more take-home pay in their paycheck
I think that public opinion is going to
change pretty quickly so you know we are
very excited we know they're getting a
tax pay cut well they'll feel it though
they'll feel it or they won't and then
they'll be able to decide what they
ultimately think think about the bill
when they see that in terms of the
carried interest loophole this is
basically something that gives hedge
fund people who run hedge funds the
ability to pay a far lower tax rate than
than your average Joe that was something
the president said he would absolutely
get rid of even though it would not make
his hedge fund friends happy in New York
why did that not happen look the
president tried to get rid of carried
interest but let's talk about what the
president actually did here the
president delivered on his four key
initiatives when we laid out what we
were gonna do in taxes we talked about
middle-class tax relief we talked about
lowering business taxes we talked about
simplification and we talked about
repatriation those were the president's
four key principles and he delivered on
all four of his key principles yes we
talked about getting rid of many many of
the loopholes and if you look at what we
achieved we did achieve getting rid of
many many loopholes we didn't get rid of
them all but we're pretty excited about
what we did get written for you as we in
the air because there was some
discussion that you might be interested
in the job of heading the Federal
Reserve that went another direction now
we're hearing that you do want to stay
at the White House if you had decided
that you wanted to leave in the
beginning of the year at any point what
has changed your mind now
look I'm very excited to be working on
president Trump's economic agenda we're
achieving a lot of great things and
we've got many more things to work on
we're starting to work on infrastructure
we're starting to work on welfare reform
these are all great opportunities for us
to really change the course of the
American economy and the American worker
and what's going on here and it's
something that a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to work out so you want to
stick around to see those things through
how would you say the mood is at the
White House in terms of the work
environment because there have been some
people that have left we've seen a
little bit of reshuffling and and are
you gonna stay all the way through 2018
look I think the mood of the White House
today is excited with our
accomplishments but everyone's very
realistic that we still have a lot of
work in front of us and we can do so
much more Gary Cohen thank you very much
we look forward to talking with you and
this capacity in the new year then we'll
see you there thank you so much